hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome let's look at or play
whatever you want to call it closure now
this is a game that I downloaded a while
ago and I can barely hear myself but
bring the this is a game that was
released on Steam recently that I wanted
to take a look at because it seemed very
interesting and I'm always I'm always
interested in these hello eh oh I'm
always interested in these unique
platforming indie games say they
intrigue me a lot and this one really
caught my eye because I mean just look
at it I've got a confused as to what's
going on but it seems ok yes job
interesting tutorial level built into
the atmosphere I like that a lot
hey I drop my org thingy okay hey okay
so the objective basically revolves
around carrying this orb around and
that's what's gonna help
woo hahaha damn that is really freaking
cool yeah I'm kind of sad that I put
this game away for a bit I should have
played this as soon as I bought it hang
on
hey whoa wat da ah ah no one told me
there was a bit of doom there what the
baloney hi yes closure I don't know what
the objective with a story of the game
is about okay okay so like most indie
games very small collection of people
making it with big dreams I always
applaud anyone who tries their hardest
to come up with a game an indie game
that can eventually succeed to be
something amazing
you dick your deck and like my other
games this is this may or may not be a
full playthrough that I go through okay
ha-ah okay so it's not just that there's
a pit its I fall through blackness if
there is no light there is no level
that's cool I like that a lot I actually
like that a lot it has a incredibly
clever idea so the whole game is based
on light so you can't go anywhere the
light doesn't let you that's incredibly
interesting ah my light come back here
now my light my life my life my light
okay my life thank you
okay my light my light follow follow
follow follow haha oh look at that I'm
literally standing on top of the light
this could be one of the most
interesting platformers I've come across
in a long time like you don't see many
mechanics built like this whoa what is
that I down there what is that
whoa reality is unraveling whoa
oh my light no my light my light my
light come back light thank you okay
let's just um go this way that was
probably a secret or an easter egg or
some special unlockable huh ah oh no ha
ha ha oh no I was supposed to push that
so other objects are affected by the
light as well no light no hope
okay so let's just carefully bring these
over all right so what's going on here
maybe I need to make that my box those
good apparently there's quite a bit of
trial and error which is common to
platformers platformers are no stranger
to trial and error but let's just keep
things in a perspective here and that
perspective has said I'm not the
greatest game player in the world I'm
pretty good at some games but bad
farmers maybe not my strategy strong
suit
I love the atmosphere in this game it's
just kind of hauntingly beautiful if
that applied to anything it definitely
applies to this I'm a light oh haha and
go down as well take an elevator that's
awesome hey wait I need that badge okay
alright just got to time this out
oh no wait there we go
huh BAM like Mouse oh whoa
give me that all right there we go got
it I'm a genius I'm the greatest ever
was still guys this is Oh what
Oh okay so ah that's so cool
I can angle these lights that's so cool
seriously this has got to be one of the
coolest game I've ever come across I'm
really actually kind of sad that they
didn't play this sooner because man this
is awesome okay I sort of need to shine
my way across there I think and how am I
gonna get over there okay maybe I can
get through there but I think I got to
go up it's just kind of hard because
okay okay that knees shined down to
illuminate the light there this needs to
shine up so that I can walk across those
things huh
let me through ah it was like their
fudge okay this needs to stay this needs
to stay about right here okay that stays
there
and then this goes over here I don't
think I need to go up so much as I just
need to get across there so I'll put
this one right cheer man this is like
making me think ah oh man this is like
making me thinking wasted I've never
imagined before like I've never had to
think of light as oh man this is beyond
all of my expectations is incredibly
cool and like I don't have any words to
describe it like seriously normally I
can commentate on things but I'm totally
unfamiliar of any game being like this
ever this is unlike anything I've ever
seen and that's perfectly apt
description of what this is and it's so
cool let me let me just try to go here I
can hop on that thing uh ah maybe I can
use this to illuminate some here
okay maybe that'll do so if I go here
and I hop yes nailed it it was those
rocks were actually blocking the light
coño red herring okay so getting it
getting it getting it nailing it nailing
it 0:24 what's that holy crap this game
would be huge I don't think I'm gonna do
a full playthrough of it I just I like
to give these indie games a look so that
you guys know what's good and what's
good out there because there are a lot
of really really interesting indie games
coming out what's happening
I changed I put on a different hat and
I'm I'm different now okay whoa whoa oh
those are stompy dudes this doesn't seem
good what has changed about me other
than I have a hat on so wha what oh man
as far as original ideas go this has got
to be the most original idea I've seen
in a long time and that is a great great
thing man I'm just really happy that I
started playing this bear shoo shoo oh
fudge what did that do oh okay I should
probably go back down the same way just
to be safe ah crap I'm good with my
light I think I can jump
what's with the clock that's not what
time it is here oh man I'm just so
excited to see creativity come out like
this because when you got your
mainstream games your triple-a titles
people people don't innovate in those
things not really anyway people often
just go with the same old same old
because
apparently it slows down a lot when you
hear in water don't know hi that's
really creepy
but I mean when you got your triple-a
titles and stuff like that people don't
often innovate or at least try try to do
something interesting and different okay
so if I what am I doing here that's
really creepy the way the music changes
when you're underwater like that okay I
don't exactly see what I'm supposed to
do maybe I think I think I might have to
drop one of these here maybe I need to
illuminate this up here I don't know I'm
just kind of confused at the moment cuz
obviously puzzle platformers they need
to be good oh I was afraid that was
gonna happen
hahaha okay oh man what was I saying I
was saying something about triple-a
titles and I don't know where I left off
anyway you got your you got your games
that are made by big game companies and
what they want to do is they want to
make money more than anything and that's
fine that's business that's the way the
world works that's what makes the world
go round but at the same time you have
an outlet for creativity unlike any
other gaming is such a novel and
interesting medium that there's
unlimited potential for ideas to be
brought to life and just creative stuff
like this that allow millions of other
people to to enjoy it depending on how
successful your game is millions of
other people to share in your idea and
enjoy the kind of you know a creativity
that you have in mind that's amazing
that's what I believe in and I believe
that indie titles are kind of the only
way that that comes to life I mean you
do have great minds like you know
anything hey any old Nintendo stuff is
an example of creativity I mean a
plumber that eats mushrooms and stomps
on Turtles I mean that now that's that's
straight out of a creative mind but at
the same time it's kind of lost in the
realm of games today and I believe it
can be caught again and I'm
I'm stalling for time because I don't
know what I'm supposed to do here it's
kind of something underwater here but I
don't know what am i doing what am i
doing yeah I don't really know hey let
me go back a bit maybe there's ah I
can't get out of the water I'm doing it
ah wait I know what I'm doing I need to
make that wall disappear so that I can
just jump across it okay
okay because if that wall isn't there
it's not a problem visit this game is
messing with my mind if the walls not
there it's not a WoW home and I gotta
think outside the box in ways I never
thought possible oh god oh god I could
get crushed in that couldn't I I'm gonna
get crushed I'm gonna get crushed in
that oh god oh god oh god run run
oh man seriously you guys in fact in a
lot of ways I don't even want to spoil
this game for you because this this is
amazing this is something that you guys
should experience for yourself and
closure was not a lot of money when I
play it when I bought it I don't recall
but it had to be under $10 I believe it
was under $10 so if I could ever
recommend the game highly enough I would
give this like ten bajillion puffs fudge
ten bajillion points like creativity out
out out the wazoo this is unbelievably
amazing like this is kind of the genre
to genre defining game there is no other
game that's like create light to reveal
the world and that's how you move
there's nothing like that and I may have
just walked myself into a corner here
oh no there we go once again she kind of
walk on the light you create to get up
it's like blowing my mind this is like
the same experience that I went through
in Portal when I first went through
portal I was just thinking of it like I
had to completely change the way that I
thought fudge oh I only need to good I
uh oh man I've nerd it out enough let's
just carry on with the game and let the
game speak for itself I have a tendency
to ramble when I don't really need to
about just silliness it doesn't haha and
I end up repeating myself a lot let's
see here what do we got what do we got
what have you got what are we doing here
hmm oh I might have needed three I
might've needed all three well but okay
let's get these two in their holes and
then I'll get the last one miner come
true all right no bill Gavin - excuse me
oh my god that yep ah there we go
and so yeah basically to anyone watching
this anyone at all please please go out
on Steam and buy closure it doesn't
matter how much it is because from what
I see this is an exceptionally long game
that'll provide you hours of
entertainment if you like puzzle
platformers which I do oh I need to move
that light that will provide you hours
of entertainment it's incredibly
immersive the idea is beyond original it
kind of goes beyond original when it's
kind of defines a whole new genre of
game it's just I can't recommend it more
I could not recommend this game more and
I'm gonna have so much fun playing the
crap out of this game later and the
reason I don't like to lose Erie's is
because I feel like if I invest my time
in a long series I don't want to be just
another let's player that does games to
play games you know to make as many
videos as possible to just make money
that's not that's not why I want to do
Let's Plays I wanted to do let's place
so that I can bring attention to really
cool games like this oh hello
oh no I needed that box bollocks all
right let me let me solve this one last
puzzle here okay I need to oh I need 100
fudge
I need this here and this that to do
that then I need to roll this ball back
and ha ha this is what I do
ha I'm so strong just look at me go I'm
so tough and manly oh man oh man I'm so
I'm so I'm so happy to find because
these are really rare gems
it is rare when you come across a truly
great game that's kind of just just the
small ah-ha
Oh bollocks I forgot to adjust the light
yabba-dabba what goblet okay one last
try here ah bollocks come on I'll go do
this how you do this I gotta think of so
many things it once I keep forgetting
that I need to watch the light I'm
standing on is beyond cool beyond cool
beyond cool okay
that'll do okay right there come on now
come on now get it out down yeah hey
come on now there we go oh man I can't
even wait to see what kind of other
puzzles they have at the end of the road
oh I guess I didn't have to push the orb
with them all that idiot okay so I think
that's a decent enough look at the game
the rest you can find out for yourselves
once again I cannot recommend this game
more it is as cool as it looks it is so
this music is awesome by the way
it is incredibly immersive and it makes
you think of puzzles in ways you never
would have thought of before I thought
there couldn't be possibly be more ways
for a puzzle platformer to innovate but
it just shows that creativity in the
indie game community is just limitless
there's so it's so cool to see something
like this happen so thank you all so
much for watching click the annotation
for more videos that I've done and I'll
try to put a link to the actual game in
steam itself in the description below so
check the description thank you
everybody for watching and as always I
will see you in the next video bye bye
Oh
[Music]
[Applause]